more heavy rain in Central Texas this
morning could bring a new round of
violent flooding nearly a foot of rain
in the past week has left houses under
water with rivers and lakes rising to
near historic levels at least one person
has died Texas governor declared
disasters in 18 counties
mark Strassmann is in Llano Texas as
northwest of Austin where people are
still in danger today mark good morning
to you good morning I want to show you
something this is the churning Llano
river behind me which in some spots rows
35 feet in 24 hours after heavy rains
people living within a quarter-mile of
both sides of the river have been
encouraged to evacuate and officials
have had to open several dams to relieve
pressure with a thunderous boom the
fast-moving water burst from the ten
open floodgates of the Matt Starkey dam
I've never seen this craig Campbell owns
a home near the dam on the Colorado
River in Marble Falls and watched his
Bowden dock get destroyed by the rushing
floodwater oh my god in Kingsland this
bridge built 49 years ago was no match
for the Llano river crumbling to pieces
as water levels topped 39 feet that
rising river which looks like waves
churning in the ocean was too much for a
bridge that was inspected just last year
and found to be structurally sound
here's the good news for people who live
on the other side they're not marooned
there is another way out but there are
those who stayed put prompting fire
officials to begin dangerous rescue
missions the water is moving so quickly
and plus the debris we just can't put
boats in that kind of water so we need
the helicopters as well authorities have
warned people to stay off the roads in
Leander Texas the driver of this school
bus was arrested after he drove around a
barricade right into a flooded road one
student on board had to be rescued from
the rushing waters while that water is
already starting to recede in some areas
county officials warn the danger is not
over it will go back up so we ask that
people please do not attempt to go back
to homes if you'd evacuated them
two more pieces of bad news here several
cellphone towers have been destroyed
which has made communication more
difficult for rescuers and then there's
the forecast more rain through Saturday
Nora Wow that is difficult mark thank
you